White Lotus 2 has way more sex.
I've asked to come and watch
some of it.
(LAUGHS)
I mean, they said it was
a closed set,
but I was able to get in.
♪ (HIP HOP MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Can I describe you to you?
-Yeah, could you?
-(LAUGHS)
Well, Tanya,
I think she means well.
I think she wants to be loved,
and you want that with Greg.
With anybody!
Yes! With anyone,
not just Greg.
Hey, where you going?
Uh, don't you want me
to wash up first?
It's hot out.
I got swamp crotch.
He's always thinking of me.
HALEY LU RICHARDSON:
Our characters are very similar,
actually.
We both are very self-involved
in our own kind of pity
and problems,
and we aren't self-aware
of how we kind of fit
into the big picture of life.
I think I'm much more self-aware
than you.
You think Tanya's self-aware?
(CHUCKLES)
Well, I mean, I think
when you're older,
you can be a narcissist
but still know
your incredible limitations.
And I think when you're young,
you don't even know they exist.
I completely agree with that.
I think that Portia thinks
that she's not the problem,
but here she is in Sicily,
and she's just been told
to get lost and basically
not be an assistant anymore.
But she takes it like the end
of the world.
I didn't tell you to stop
being an assistant.
I still want you
to do everything.
I need all of your help.
I'm not dismissing you at all.
I want to stay-- stay close
'cause I might need you,
but just lay low and not come
out of your room. Okay?
That's the thing, too,
about Tanya's version of "help"
and the things she "needs
an assistant for."
I think in the first episode
is the only time
you really see Portia
kind of being an assistant,
like she comes into the resort
holding bags
and telling the bellman
where to put things.
But then, when you tell me
to go to my room,
I'm still kind of on call
for you,
but it's really just a lot
of sitting in the other room
while you're crying, or like,
-standing there.
-What's wrong with that?
Well, I hope by the next
few episodes, you evolve.
(CHUCKLES) Yeah!
You think there's hope?
I-- I certainly hope so, because
your lack of appreciation...
-(CHUCKLING)
-for-- for anything.
That's true.
Very entitled.
Yeah.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
I think I would rather
actually go alone
than with any of the characters
other than Lucia.
She's very beautiful. I mean,
she actually makes
most people's trip better.
(SPEAKING ITALIAN)
I always show up with, like,
eight suitcases
when I go on a trip, and then,
when you open up the luggage,
it has nothing that I could
possibly wear,
nothing that's right
for the trip.
I show up, and I have
all these stupid things
that I don't need
in my hotel room.
I don't know why.
Well, also,
it's been freezing here,
and we thought, you know, like
Sicily in the spring and summer,
it's gonna be so hot.
But we got here,
and it's been freezing cold,
and everyone's bought
puffer jackets.
(SHIVERING)
I love the desert.
Like a deserty mountain to hike.
I don't know if that's
the most popular opinion
for a vacation, but I feel
most at home in the desert.
I want to always go where
everything is ancient.
You know, I wanna stay
in some really old castle.
When someone says,
"Oh, my god, Jennifer,
we're gonna go to this place.
We're renting this house,
and we found it
on a really cool website."
And I'm like, "Is it old?"
Because if it's not old
and crumbling and cool,
I have no interest.